alors que certains de ses camarades de
classe sont en vacances enzo est déjà de
retour en classe à 15 ans il rêve de
devenir mécanicien automobile
là on va enlever la courade distribution
qui est placé dans le moteur ici donc on
va déjà commencer par enlever cette
partie puis ensuite partir pour aller
voir la courroie pendant le confinement
impossible pour lui de réaliser des
cours de pratique il est donc venu
volontairement suivre cette semaine de
cours d'été proposées par son
établissement
on n'avait pas des voitures à réparer on
n'avait pas des moteurs à disposition
donc là c'est bien comme ça on a un
atout pour s'entraîner pour apprendre
c'est ça qui est bien de revenir ici
quelques cours théoriques mais surtout
des cours de pratique comme la
maintenance des véhicules ou encore la
conduite routière sur poids lourds
guillaume martin et professeur de
conduite routière et pilote de camions
en compétition lui remarque la
motivation de ses élèves pour ses cours
de rattrapage on a des jeunes qui ont
fait des projets qui font des projets et
qui veulent les mener à bien et qui sont
volontaires à nous de suivre et
justement c'est ce qu'on propose c'est
de leur donner la possibilité de faire
ce qu'ils ont envie de faire et ça ils
ont envie de le faire le décrochage
touche principalement les lycées
professionnels dans cet établissement 25
élèves sont concernés par ce dispositif
mis en place et dix professeurs présents
pour encadrer les lycées nous sommes sur
un temps hors temps scolaire avec à
l'accompagnement personnalisé de la part
d'un enseignant donc je pense que
l'élève le lycéen professionnel est
satisfait d'avoir un petit peu l'oreille
l'écoutent et le savoir-faire de
l'enseignant qui justement sera plus
personnalisés à la fin de l'été une
deuxième session sera disponible pour
aborder la rentrée plus sereinement